Android 8.1 Oreo contains a targeted set
of enhancements including optimizations
for Android Go and a new neural networks
API we've also included a few smaller
enhancements in response to user and
developer feedback Android 8.1 includes
memory optimizations for Android Go
hardware that has one gigabyte or less
of RAM for example notification listener
service and condition provider service
will not be supported on low Ram devices
in addition we've added new hardware
feature constants so you can now target
the distribution of your apps and apk
splits to normal or low ram devices if
they're running Android 8.1 and later
we've been working hard to bring on
device machine intelligence to mobile
with features such as Now Playing and
google lense the new neural networks API
lays the foundation for our developer
community to build accelerated on device
applications of machine learning
including image recognition and
prediction the neural networks API
runtime is designed to efficiently
distribute the computation workload
across available on device processors
including dedicated neural network
hardware graphics processing units and
digital signal processors for devices
that lack a specialized vendor driver or
hardware the runtime relies on optimized
code to execute requests on the CPU it's
unlikely that most apps will use the
neural networks API directly they'll
instead rely on a higher-level machine
learning framework such as tensorflow
lite or cafe to tensorflow lite is
Google's cross-platform open-source
framework designed to execute deep
trained neural networks in mobile
environments and it's scheduled to be
released soon so make sure to stay tuned
we also are investing bringing the
benefits of deep learning to more
developers so we intend to release a
library to make common ml use cases
easily available on mobile devices
Android 8.1 Oreo as a new shared memory
API this new API enables the creation of
an anonymous shared memory instance you
can nmap the shared memory object into a
local byte buffer and breed and write it
like any other byte buffer the memory
protection can be controlled on the
shared object since the shared memory
object is parsable
you can easily pass it to another
process through a IDL the remote process
can then map any part of the memory it
wants and once access is no longer
needed
just unmapped the buffer the shared
memory API also supports
interoperability with the NDK using a
shared memory
we can end that the F D and then read
and write it's a great way to share data
between multiple processes within a
single app or even between apps we've
added some polish and refinement to
autofill most of the changes are on the
autofill Service side for example the
save UI now supports custom descriptions
so when asking to save credit card data
the service can request the display of a
logo representing the type of credit
card the last four digits of the card
number and an expiration date this helps
the user understand exactly what is
being saved one minor change for apps
that want to support autofill is that
base adapter and it's derived classes
such as array adapter now supports
setting autofill options this makes it
easier to provide autofill data for
simple custom adapters such as one used
to set credit card expiration dates in
Android 0 you would need to override to
get autofill method options in the
adapter but now in 8.1 you can just call
set autofill options and in another
helpful touch the API 27 version of the
support library view compat now wraps
the autofill methods to make it easier
to give hints to the audit fill service
which you really should do one more
autofill note consider setting up an
association between your app and your
website this allows the autofill service
to share passwords between the two
whether you're on android 8.0 or android
8.1 Android 801 includes new api is in
the wallpaper manager to get the most
representative colors from the current
wallpaper and the system UI and pixel
launcher will adjust the colors they use
based upon this api if you've made a
live wallpaper you notify the wallpaper
service whenever your colors change
significantly returning them in the on
compute colors method we recommend using
the utility functions within the
wallpaper colors class to automatically
select these colors from a
representative bitmap or drawable some
other changes you might be interested in
edit text now returns an editable rather
than a care sequence your app can
determine how it responds to a known
threat from the webview implementation
of the Safe Browsing API the media
metadata Retriever class has a new
method get scaled frame at time that
finds a frame near a given time position
and returns a bitmap with the same
aspect ratio as a source frame but at
the requested size if you have any pixel
or pixel two device we support
requesting a audio sharing mode
exclusive in some cases which provides
reduced audio latency better yet we've
released a preview of the oboe library
which allows applications to target a
API 26 plus devices and opensl on
previous versions of Android to get the
best latency with a simplified API
surface in a compatible way if you have
a pixel to you'll notice a developer
setting in Android 8.1 for camera Hal
hdr+ this enables you to test an early
version of HDR plus with pixel visual
core Google's first costume design
coprocessor for consumer products note
that hdr+ will only be enabled for
specific camera and camera to API
options if you have an eligible pixel or
Nexus device you can enroll it in
Android beta to get the latest update
but we also have Android 8.1 emulator
images this gives you the opportunity to
fix any issues that update your app
before consumers get their hands on 8.1
you can find out more about everything
we covered including the Developer
Preview program here happy coding
[Music]